[Musique]
il était attendue et espérée après une
courte formation en gériatrie
les militaires sont arrivés en ch et
celle des entre autres à villa val des
arbres
à laval on va aller le même tempo que
d'autres dans le fond vu qu'on est plus
on est là pour viser les et des bains
savoie alléger leur charge du renfort
pour cinq établissements jugés
prioritaires par québec en plus de laval
il y a le manoir de verdun la résidence
yvon brunet à ville-émard l'hôpital
sainte anne et le centre valeo à saint
lambert
ici en plus de 49% de résidents affectés
une vingtaine d'employés sont atteints
c'était catastrophique
c'était catastrophique l'impact sur les
soins que reçoit la mère de jean pierre
chez l'eau se fait sentir
ma mère lui a dit micheline je n'ai
jamais autant crier dans ma vie pour
avoir de l'aide
c'est pas normal une réalité répandue
benoît tremblay a reçu l'appel sa mère
est infecté ça nous inquiète ce sont la
famille toute la famille est inquiète
par rapaces il est toutefois rassuré de
voir l'aide arriver
en fait tous les gens qui peuvent aider
sa voiture est une bonne chose mais on
va essayer d'aller voir si comme avant
moment c'est ça l'important
dans les rangs militaires il y à des
infirmières et des techniciens médicaux
comme le caporal mathieu bergeron à ce
mauvais c'est surtout des soins ou lit
on a changé les patients on est chargé d
hydro qui termine son premier quart à la
résidence villa val des arbres mais
c'est un objectif d'un mini-centre
chisinau on est sur notre territoire
c'est nogent pis on a la chance de
prendre soin de notre monde comme si une
belle opportunité
les militaires vont se changer après
leur quart à la résidence pour éviter la
contagion avant de retourner sur la base
militaire à saint-jean-sur-richelieu
l'endroit où ils vont rester tout au
long de l'opération dans les ch est
celle d une opération qui n'a pas de
date prévue de fin et si jacques andré
charbonneau radio-canada là bas